on sent ces pionniers du changement qui
ont vieilli et un pionnier ma définition
de reprise c'est à tokyo voulons c'est
quelqu'un qui sort des sentiers battus
et il semble qu'on ne peut pas dire
qu'il y ait du changement si on commence
par soi même on peut voir les tribunes
je vous fais partager avec eux ce soir
c'est des trucs et des exercices de
psychologie positive des informations de
psychologie positive qui vont peut-être
vous aider à vous en êtes me démange de
savourer la nes de savoir où en étaient
les souffrances qu'elles sont épaisses
le jeu vers les jeux à savoir d'abord en
une année avant de pouvoir frayer un
génie sortir deux sentira permettre à
d'autres de nous fait donc que commencer
vous pouvez jouer les durs
[Musique]
qui quand vous le col et change la vie
c'est le leadership à la sauce est le
négatif de l'institution maïs ça veut
dire à intensité égale des événements de
nature négatifs vont avoir un effet
puissant sur votre cerveau que des
événements de nature productif et en
poursuivant les études leur a souhaité
de mains habiles stade il vous faudrait
lui événement positif avant dans une
journée pour doubler un seul événement
mais auxerre est ce qui se passe ça va
se gâter d'expérience et ce n'est pas
que j'ai vécue par les gens qui vont
faire que on va développer des préjugés
on va développer des sérotypes et on va
surtout par rapport à soi même ce crazy
des huit ans sa devront commencer et les
parents
notre vie élégamment elle est
complètement juste histoire de l'océanie
et encore plus du tout avoir de google
sur les jours et en fait voile est ce
que j'ai partagé avec tous et surtout
des saucisses et des bourses qui va vous
permettre de contourner ce débat celui
qui passe pour pouvoir quatre premiers
de vous même et être un peu y ait du
changement donc que le creux des points
quand je voulais était souhaitée avec
vous cette histoire d'après ses émotions
et les aventures manger tout si ça a
marché à la fin qui est un peu qu'on ait
fait les arrangements conclus entre un
désir veille
musicologie positive et en fait c'est
quelqu'un que je trouve que c'est elle
qui m'a reconnu et en fait on s'est
salués et elle m'a dit qu'elle va vivre
pour moi j'allais vous voir vous allez
être un brin de s'outiller la
psychologie positive à dire est que
c'est le but ultime de quoi discuter
rapidement pendant cinq minutes
et justement dans six états
démocratiques en avait un aujourd'hui et
je suis étudiant vous êtes jeunes
on vit dans un assaut
ce dif 1 j'ai mangé doit publier demain
jeandon méditer émergents on en dénombre
un saut au savon et du coup d une
expérience en cours d'évolution du matif
ne se sent pas très bien elle m'aurait
gêné ou deux ou trois ans on a tendance
à bloquer notre envie d'en comprendre et
est en fait tous
si on ne se permet pas d'accepter ses
besoins des aveugles et des stabilité et
surtout le plus important parcourra tout
ça c'est de les questionner et 213 jours
à nous accorder on va mal parce que
finalement ces émotions les gatinois qui
vous permet vraiment de savoir kevin et
ses émotions et que tu sois qui nous
importe quand on les laisse visiter
qu'on les apprentis sur les questions
[Musique]
voilà sept ans mais subit donc
satisfaire de nous c'est un super moment
où elle est cruciale
elle parle
à avoir 10 décrit justement sur le ton
de la rigolade
un petit peu d'individus s'il exprime en
moins de besoins éducatifs s'il faut pas
que des morts on compte déjà 6 demandée
c'est que c'est que tous ravis et le
fait de les accepter va réellement vos
chargeurs c'est le premier je voulais
terminer
[Musique]
qui me touche beaucoup et que j'attends
de yumi un délit dans ces cas dans les
années 20 est en fait utilisé son neveu
pas arrivé de l'extérieur se forme de
best-of et il ya très souvent on compte
aussi des personnes dans leurs familles
dans 37,6 à exarchia je savais à travers
les autres à travers l'environnement
alors que tout simplement passionnés
nous avons justement trois saisons il
faut que le deuxième point donc ça c'est
jean coulé face à ces gens un certain
justin bieber mais c'est justement
développer ce soir ça c'est bien
et en fait on voulait voir avec vous si
vous êtes des étudiants qui ont péri et
que on parle camion obtienne ce sens
c'est surtout l'idée de nous tous ps
fait quelque chose
oser faire des cheveux ne fait pas la
pratique il faut absolument essayer
d'éviter ça parce qu'en fait c'est sûr
c'est que vous allez vous retrouver à
prendre en compte 50 ans dans une quête
de sens va plus avoir aucun sens et que
vous avez des questions j'en suis
arrivée là oui ma vie oui j'ai tout pour
être heureux finalement ça ne soit pas
pourquoi parce que j'ai fait des choses
pratiques
donc le fait de se dire d'où ces
[Musique]
publicités sur moi si vous journée où 50
des dépôts
[Musique]
si je devais donner une image de tentes
et à défaut si vous avez la chance de
passion et de sang vous et vous avez
compté les points et un moment vous
allez donner de téléphone et ça va faire
que ça va être votre vie amoureuse de
paris en sauvant ses deux matchs devant
son public à savoir et vous en faite
[Musique]
c'est d'avoir la chance ça fasse un
question les émotions négatives en
partie est en fait à un moment le besoin
que je savais faire
ce à dire que vous allez découvrir leur
quotidien
[Musique]
le troisième point savoirs essentiels
c'est la résilience c'est à dire qu'il
faut développer sa capacité de
résilience
je sais que ces gars de chez vous ça
fait partie d'une personnalité c'est pas
quelque chose qui m'inquiète c'est
quelque chose que l'on peut acquérir
c'est quelque chose sur lequel on peut
travailler en commun 127 pas essayer
l'exercice du client pour la résilience
c'est de passer de s'extraire de 200
heures s'adresser de favoriser alisation
de se voir un peu de temps car moment de
se poser dans un coin et d'essayer de
s'observer d'avoir dans une chambre
d'étudiant ensuite dans sa ville ensuite
dans son pays en lui et on s'extrait
comme la balance est de réaliser en fait
que c'est juste trop petit il ya un an
que comme vous aidera et que vous
souhaitez apprendre la vie ne deviendra
principal du tout qu'ils vont résider en
fait est ainsi des périodes difficiles
pour en parler
superbe et l'image un crime mais c'est
super j'en vois pas bien mais j'en
prends par exemple pour les vols qui
sont passés ils ont un une activité
qu'ils appellent une souris est en fait
les banques y sont passés où les deux
jeunes et et blanc personnel il est 20 h
salle avec avec une leur faudra vers lui
mais l'ingénieur de bord pratique de
l'argent et en fait ça fait des bols
lycéens artistique c'est le meilleur
sens du john travolta s'est donné encore
plus belles à voir cette verrée de cesse
des noirs est en fait le récit
voile bien je suis excité que j'étais
diffusion de la récession du fait pour
la question à qui elle réside et on sera
vendu fait on va et son hongre à faire
et que ce sont plus grands que ce n'est
pas juste moi jamais je n'y avais pas
pensé
donc mes 6 ans sont catastrophiques
s'ils gagnent à première vue et dans le
fonctionnement des réessayer est un des
exercices on peut faire sécession
[Musique]
le résident aussi développer sa pratique
gratitude ces points contre 827 c'est à
dire de ne pas être plus en permanence
sur ce qu'on pourrait avoir sur ses
amours le nous poser seins nus et se
concentrer sur son nom aujourd'hui mais
ça c'est vachement congo est en fête et
compatit 3 commence à devenir
actionnaire c'est par votre cerveau à
cannabis trois semaines fils hervé
parent que dormir tous les soirs vous
prenez votre avez vous noté tous les
éléments qui perfore qui se trouve pas
cette fois dans la journée
donc c'est peut être juste à vous avez
mangé extraordinaire en fait ce qu'il
faut c'est que au moment où vous êtes en
train de dire ça
l'anguille les fois d'après vous est ce
vraiment de cette chose-là votre cerveau
l'ex aliments plus sains cité et 3
c'est-à-dire tout à fait quand vous
allez d'expérimenter des choses cool
au quotidien ça va cogner permanent et
vous avez besoin vous nous gratifie
instinctivement
ça c'est pour la multitude et je voulais
partagez cette image aurait comme si
vous vouliez biens se désole et
d'ailleurs c'est juste une image crise
de manager southern de ceux qui forment
dans un puits et de connaissances elric
ans c'est-à-dire lé barrage asie de l
est tranquille important person et de
huit mois que c'est que depuis ce n'est
pas elle n'était pas là en train de
m'attendre
donc là la grosse ficelle que ça c'est à
dire de prendre savons nous vous le jour
profiter et moi les choses s'améliorent
et que et comme elle fonde en beignets
on ne sait rien n'est pas forcément le
plus grand et cie pas l'important c'est
surtout de se mettre dans une démarche
[Musique]
non c'était vraiment dans une démarche
de continuer dans une démarche les
objectifs et pour vous conduire à chaque
fois derrière l'objectif
le travail est en mouvement car vous
avez vous aussi vous voulez on vous les
hawks a détruit chaque rayon ccfa vous
dites c'est en ayant cette maison-là en
mariant meilleur et d'aval je vais être
que ça ne sera jamais comme ça c'est
votre cerveau à hama profiter du moment
présent et pour le moment présent il est
perdu et ont bien géré et donc du coup
c'est vraiment une question et je vous
dis puisque les expérimentés quand
j'avais votre âge
ce que je me disais oui quand je vois
avant que réaliser en fait j'étais juste
en train de perdre dans les groupes
belges ma vie a estimé qu'elle passe et
ce qui est hyper triste
donc je prends la la liste en gt gt avec
les étudiants de parfum discret et
jeunes gens afin qu'ils aient voulu
parler
un moment et qu'elle préfère discuter et
ses imprimantes
aujourd'hui john casablanca qu'est ce
que tu fais sans nous poser d'objectifs
ce que tu fais aujourd'hui pour pouvoir
bien malgré elle savait pas vraiment et
en fait ce que j'ai proposé c'est
d'aller voir des jeunes créateurs qui
sépare condamné le mois de c'est
travailler avec un peu rapidement
d'abord à lens arras d'avoir des filles
bac etc etc avant des enjeux à
s'améliorer de s'occuper de tout en
essayant
c'est pas du tout son boulet maire il ya
un grand gars d'encre entre le x parce
qu'on se fait quelque chose dépend de
comment ça fonctionne et donc du coup il
faut jouer c'est faire les choses et je
baignais de pratique pas ce qui va faire
un petit tube souffrance à la méditation
je pense que vous en avez vu comment
comparer parce que c'est très à la mode
en ce moment
et ce qui roule plupart des gens peuvent
voler ses bijoux donc tu dit ça serait
quand même encore une fois on passe des
documents personnels ces dernières
années a indiqué que vous êtes sûrement
son petit pied avec une bougie carf et
de la beauté en fait c'est juste qu'ils
méditent et ça veut dire par jour entre
petit et son comité
donc ça c'est un mot critique
c'est la fondation
désormais paris xii 1970 par jour et
dans ses idées en fait un crime at il
toujours négatif au début et donc du
coup ce qui s'est passé peut le moins
c'est dur aujourd'hui j'ai on va dire
simplement une idée parce qu'un appel
l'extrême majorité d'entre elles sur
demont négatif j'ai redoublé toujours
les mêmes c'est à dire qu'on va 15% des
métiers d'aujourd'hui pour les gammes
possède le double aussi de le méditer
pour prendre le temps de célébrer tout
juste prendre le temps de se calmer et
de faire vite
si je ne prends pas comme me disais je
pense à autre chose et je n'arrive pas à
garder les idées claires dans la tête
que je peux
en fait je perds je l'entends a
concentré donc juste vous avez une image
des jours deux fils ce depuis 30 ans
déjà il ya beaucoup prendre une surprise
donc me disais au départ qu'ils font
mais dit-il
lorsque vous voyez
dix à quinze jours ça les aide à ce
congrès est revenue ces données données
c'est-à-dire donner est parti de travers
c'est à dire synthé révélé dagneux est
en fait juste pour pour clôturer là où
ils ont pris les gens ils ont vu leurs
revenus mobiles ont pris des gens qui
avaient des revenus divers pourrait
dépenser cet argent est en fait se sont
rendu compte que les gens qui dépensent
à cet argent ce qui va par le plus
important qu'on a dépensé dans les
autres étaient plus ou moins et ils ont
dit oui
[Musique]
ce week-end by kevin warwick geragos
d'olonne le procureur beaucoup plus de
dépenses et pour nous mais surtout
d'amour et
pour ce soir en vous parlant du fait
qu'on parle souvent de il faut se
trouver il faut trouver ce qu'on lui
fait j'ai horreur de ça après il faut
juste retourner à soi même peut-être
toutes les informations dont vous avez
besoin ce que toi vous êtes vous n'êtes
pas fait souffrir des couches de
prévention de les gagner pas de famille
pour tous etc et famille tôt pour nous
avoue même être honnête avec vous même
et c'est à méditer et pratiquer notre
attitude et ses terreurs de groupes
cette source en est pour vous l'avez
trouvé de la partager avec un maximum de
personnes possible et je voulais finir
cette façon de birmingham ce qu'ils
disaient et j'espère que vous allez à la
rencontre avec vous même et que vous
allez promotion ses excès et que je
devais m'accidenter tout comme à la fois
je me sens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]